malaysia's former prime minister najib
razak has been sentenced to 12 years
in jail after he was convicted of
corruption
the verdict was delivered in the first
trial linked to the one mdb
state investment fund scandal during his
time in power
naji was found guilty of all seven
charges and fined close to 50 million us
dollars he continues to deny any
wrongdoing and says he will appeal
this is the first case centered on the
transfer of nearly 10 million dollars
from a unit of 1
mdb into najeeb's personal accounts
he's been convicted of abusive power
three counts of criminal breach of trust
and three counts of money laundering
najib launched one mdb
as a state investment fund when he was
prime minister in 2009. okay let's go
across to florence louis
who's joining us live from kuala lumpur
florence just bring us up to date with
what's been happening
right so we know that the judge has um
sentenced najib razak to
a prison prison term as well as a fine
of 210
million bring it um now what we know is
also that the defense lawyers are asking
for an a stay of execution of the
sentence
so they're arguing that najib razak
shouldn't go to prison immediately that
he should be allowed to stay
outside of prison be able to carry out
his duties as a member of parliament
until his appeal at the court of appeal
has been hurt
and this is a process that could take
months years even
and we don't yet know whether this um
this argument by
najib's defense lawyers is going to be
successful whether the judge is going
to grant a stay of execution of the
sentence or not
but we do know that the prosecution has
argued that granting a stay of such um
granting a stay is really the exception
rather than
the general rule while you've been
talking florence i just want to
show people a live pictures from outside
the court there which we're seeing at
the moment this is the
the press waiting because we understand
that the uh the prime minister may well
be
uh leaving from there at the moment
where obviously if you make some sort of
statement we will be taking it but at
the moment
we're waiting to see what's what's
happening those negotiations that you're
talking about
continuing between his lawyers which
means that this is by no means over
is it
no this is not over um at all i mean
you know there's still an appeal process
that najib can take advantage of
he's been found guilty of all seven
charges
um and you know he's been sentenced to
12 years in prison the judge has said
these
his his jail sentences are to run
concurrently
um and the maximum of those sentences is
12 years in prison but he still has an
appeals process to the court of appeal
and even that after that has been
exhausted if the
verdict is not in his favor he can still
appeal to the highest court in the land
that's the federal court so this is a
process that
could take years and obviously najib and
his lawyers want to ensure that
if he can still take um take advantage
of the appeals process then he doesn't
want to be spending those years where
he's appealing his verdict
behind bars there is a political
ramification to this isn't there because
um the natives party is also a key part
or has formed a key part of the
coalition government
um in malaysia and therefore one wonders
how much
responsibility or rather how much power
and control
najib rajaf is going to be able to carry
on
until such times as his sentencing does
come in because as you say there was an
expectation or
a hope at least by his defense that he
would be allowed to carry on his
parliamentary duties until
that decision was finally made
absolutely now najib is no longer the
leader of the united malays national
organization that's um
that's the biggest block in the ruling
alliance but he still has um he still
enjoys very strong political support
within the party and also outside of the
party
we saw how high-ranking party officials
including the president
were at court today to show their
support for najib
and this is a party that the current
administration relies on to keep their
really
thin parliamentary majority now
um there isn't yet a sense of of
how upset the uh party is about this
decision
whether or not it's going to put
pressure on the
ruling administration to go for snap
elections but on the other hand
now some analysts say that this
conviction on tuesday
will provide a lot of credibility to the
prime minister meridian yasin's
administration and this is important
because in the last several weeks last
several months
we've seen people have expressed dismay
and disappointment at how
high profile corruption cases seem to
have gone away they've either been
settled or the charges have been dropped
now one of those cases involves najib's
stepson another case involved
a political ally of najib so
um some analysts say the prime minister
mourinho
may still be able to gain some sort of
political mileage out of this conviction
that's florence louis bringing us up to
date from kuala lumpur we're going to be
of course keeping across that situation
outside the courtroom
in kuala lumpur and we will be talking
to florence in the event that
there's something to report there but
for now florence thank you very much
indeed